yo tout le monde sait ce qu dire joue ne
se retrouvent sur forgotten un jeu
d'horreur même si ça n'en n'a absolument
pas l'air en fait il faut juste franchir
cette porte pour accéder à un univers
absolument terrible alors j'aimerais
bien que ça marche
oui parce que j'essaie juste avant et ça
ne guérit complètement on a juste un
briquet d'ailleurs là qui est
extrêmement mal fait bon c'est pas grave
alors on est perdu dans une [ __ ] de
forêt une maison très bien bref chevaux
soit déjà trouvé le truc on va pas
chercher plus loin
c'est quoi ça m'inspire tellement pas
confiance très bien et voit la fin du
jeu ceux ci étaient terriblement pendant
alors je dors isoc
ok très bien la deuxième à elle peut
souffrir bon les gens mon niveau en
anglais est vraiment pas terrible
autant vous dire que je vais pas tout
comprendre et à vrai dire là apparemment
on s'en bat les steaks de ce qu'il y
avait maintenant dix secondes devant la
peau d'un psychopathe qui consulte un
psy quels sont vos progrès monsieur en
fait je vais tuer comment ça vous allait
me tuer
parmi eux les bienvenus la suze côté m
en fait je suis dans une église d'accord
c'est très très glauque mesdames et
messieurs ce soir nous faisons grève
voilà bon alors attendez ce qu'on peut
pas aller là non dans cette porte-là non
plus peut-être dans cette lampe et bien
non il ya un lien se tient juste devant
c'est bien ça c'est la bible c'est la
bible bois sans déconner un que tu
pouvais être ce bouquin dans une église
un peut-être les comptes de petites
princesses
non arf j'ai trouvé la cave que c'est
que ça une [ __ ] de mini maison
je sais que cette chose un bouton un
bouton inutile très bien d'accord au
lait café le jeu il s'est carrément
taper une barre quoi on va mettre une
sorte d'immeubles aux miniatures juste
dans ce coin un sens absolument aucune
raison voilà moi je suis la technique du
longe âge de mur parce que j'ai une
grosse [ __ ] et se doit bien servir à
quelque chose cette espèce de 2min
appartement là un aller sans te nafila
hobbit prix du coco bonds j'ai ma vie je
me casse je vais à l'extérieur mais
motherfucker wattao [ __ ] mais j'ai
peur des bruits de genre là je veux 1er
juin mon coeur il a fait un petit aa tri
qui leur est déjà à peut-être une
trouvaille
arf fois-là l'attrait à valhalla on est
bien au bois la terre phoques alors que
ce cas là dedans un berceau très bien
une espèce de poupées macaques très bien
aussi c'est à chacun sait jouer un bon
il y en a qui jouent à être ken et
barbie et d'autres qui jouent avec des
poupées macabres très bien très bien je
respecte vos choix juste là on a plein
de bruit il ya plein de saut comme ça tu
as fuck assez les fuites nocturne tu as
la flemme d'aller jusqu'à des toilettes
à
oh [ __ ] j'ai eu des frissons je vous
promets j'ai eu des poils comme les
poulets là où es tu fuck what the fuck
adacore a très bien
j'adore ouailles un bébé où es-tu mon
enfant je viens what what en sommes à ya
de lumière il doit être là vient la
douce enfant vient laquelle un ya pas de
bébé il monde il n'y a pas de début mais
tous sont là près de toi bien là à bien
la montée bien mais oui tu je reviens le
gros pétard d'église quoi aller chacun
sa gueule ah oui je crois qu'il sa veut
dire qu'il est pas content et parfois la
porte
tu as fuck yeah toucher au but
cette fois j'ai cru qu'il était mort
oulala ouanna à biberons les biberons
divin j'arrive petit baby tient à
voici la réaction de toute fille face à
un bébé 1 c'est bien ça peut être le
bébé le plus moche du monde comme celui
là elles diront toujours aille encore
une clé personne ne saura jamais mon
enfant ou qui dort bien qui dort bien le
petit bébé est visible ça faisait un peu
psychopathe cette phrase oui ça fait
peur on dirait des yeux las espèce de
petit quelqu'un je leur qui pleurent
vanessa vanessa je suis là où il ya le
nom sali lui faut le prendre ou non il
veut mais prenant source
maintenant si c'est encore un enfant
invisible que voulez vous que je fais
avec prend ce [ __ ] de teddy bordel bon
allez on va aller voir ce qui se fera du
côté du bébé puisqu'il a créé un petit
coup mon petit bébé tu as fait un gros
coeur car cola c'est ça what do joon ho
on va arrêter de faire semblant d'avoir
quelque chose à [ __ ] ah parce qu on
s'en bat les steaks voilà bon alors on
va prendre cette clé et on va se diriger
le mec qui a même plus un brin
d'humanité en 8es un bébé qui meurt il
fait je m'en bats les c
alors est-ce qu'on veuille ou non c'est
non où es tu ville un brigand you all
look the doors you finish de démo j'ai
fini la démo où est dieu ville un
brigand tuées dans ce tube wata font
rien
d'accord il ya du sang et on saute dans
le trou et je tourne depuis ça bientôt
c'est à ces courses pas ma faute s'il
joue été court mais il était bien
attention à quoi on sait quoi m'occuper
d'un bébé même s'il s'est fait tuer bon
je ne serais jamais venu et sitr à
bientôt tout le monde pis
oui